the Democratic presidential field is
getting more crowded New York senator
Kirsten Gillibrand officially entered
the race yesterday other Democratic
contenders hit the campaign trail over
the weekend and a potential candidate is
attracting a lot of attention ed O'Keefe
is in Washington you've been busy
good morning good morning bianna he's
not in at least not yet but former Vice
President Joe Biden continues to cast a
shadow over the Democratic field over
the weekend the newest guy in the
contest bet too O'Rourke faced closer
scrutiny but it was a verbal slip up by
Biden that caused the biggest stir by
the most progressive record of anybody
running for the United right Joe Biden
addressing Delaware Democrat Saturday
night hinted pretty hard at an
announcement expected next month we have
to bring this country back together it's
a matchup president Trump told CBS news
last year he'd welcome I dream about
Biden that's a dream meanwhile newcomer
Beto O'Rourke quickly went from a big
start to closer scrutiny national
Republicans tweeted this image on st.
Patrick's Day using O'Rourke's formal
name and reminding voters of his drunk
driving arrests in Texas over 20 years
ago and Orcs fellow Democrats took aim
at comments he made in a magazine
profile in Vanity Fair you said I was
born to do this yes I do feel that I
have some ability to connect with people
to bring people together senator Amy
Klobuchar seemed to mock the idea I
wasn't born to run for office just
because growing up in the 70s in the
middle of the country I don't think many
people thought a girl could be President
yesterday New York senator Kirsten
Gillibrand became the sixth female
candidate to enter the race that's why
I'm running for president some of her
male opponents like senator Cory Booker
addressed the prospect of a female
running mate I have my way
there will be a woman on the ticket now
our Rourke's team says he raised a
record-breaking 6.1 million dollars in
the first 24 hours of his campaign the
former Texas congressman ranks fifth in
a recent poll of Iowa Democrats Joe
Biden sits on top of that pole like we
said at the beginning he's not in yet
but the former veep looms large Gale
he's getting in and he's getting in
thank you very much Elsie we will see
you're absolutely right about that